in just over two weeks MPs will have the
chance to vote on the Prime Minister's
brexit deal for a fourth time
and on a visit to Northern Ireland this
week the brexit secretary Stephen
Barclay told me that if the deal is
voted down again there No Deal
preparations need to be snapped up Quinn
Industrial Holdings
straddles the invisible line between
Northern Ireland and the Republic if
there is one reason for the brexit
deadlock the 310 mile border is it a
conundrum yet to be solved Quinn's is
one of the area's biggest employers with
workers customers and sites on both
sides of the border the company makes
921 crossings every single day no wonder
authors wanted to show the bricks that
secretary the realities they face it's
your first visit to Northern Ireland as
Secretary of State what have people been
telling you well there's a clear message
from both the business community and
also the workers have been speaking to
that they want to see a deal they want
the certainty that that will bring in
terms of investment there's huge
optimism as to the potential to grow the
businesses here and people want to see
the government and Parliament move
forward with a deal with the certainty
it brings and that's been a very clear
message both from small businesses and
also some of their larger businesses
have been speaking to are you more
worried about the prospect of no deal
after coming here but there's a very
good illustration as to why we need a
deal when you look at businesses like
this you see those movements you refer
to Sophie you see the fact that the
workers come from both sides of the
board and no one wants to see a return
to the past a very clear desire to
ensure we continue to safeguard the
achievements of the Good Friday
Agreement that's always been the clear
commitment of the prime minister is the
clear commitment of the United Kingdom
and that's very much the wish of the
community here and they have a very
clear message to members of parliament
across the UK that it is now time to get
a deal to move forward and to allow them
the businesses here to get on with what
they do best which is growing their
business and creating jobs you clearly
feel that our deal is really important
the government is bringing the same deal
back again
what's the point I mean is self-evident
lot we've been in talks with the Labour
Party we've been exploring issues around
workers rights environmental standards
what commitments can be given to
Parliament in terms of the next phase
and negotiation works reminding people
that this is a deal that delivers on the
referendum vote in terms of a control of
our immigration control of our fishing
control of our agriculture and but does
so in ways that address the concerns
you're referring to here address the
concerns of businesses on the border who
are doing these journeys back and forth
it's clear that you think it's a good
deal it's clear that you sincerely
believe that this is the best option but
it's not going to get through oh that's
the point actually that members of
parliament do need to face facts
then the issue so far is if the deal
were not to go through then we there are
only two other alternatives you either
don't leave and I think I'll be a huge
betrayal to our democratic system I
think it sent a very bad message
internationally in terms of the UK's
reputation around the world and any idea
or a second referendum is just a proxy
for revoke it's for people that aren't
prepared to be candid when they say they
want a second referendum what they
really want is to avert they're just not
prepared to say it and so we either
leave with no deal or we revoke or the
far better option is to actually leave
with the certainty of what the community
here and many of us are saying which is
with the deal is that your preferred
option then if the deal doesn't get
through you'd prefer to leave well I've
always said that to revoke the biggest
democratic decision in our history would
be disastrous I think it'd be
fundamentally wrong and so whilst I've
always been clear with my colleagues
that I think a No Deal outcome is
disruptive I think there'd be clear
concerns a community like this around
the consequence of No Deal
but if Parliament won't back a deal then
it needs to confront that reality and I
do think we then in that instance need
to bring forward our preparations to
mitigate No Deal because that will need
to use the additional time we have and
we will need to move at pace to do so
I've been a bit of a frustration to you
that those preparations for No Deal have
not been continuing apace as you put it
well this issues might have been done in
government
my department has been at the heart of
our in terms of preparing for No Deal no
what's we remembering is been taken
seriously enough do you think well we
need to do more and use the time that we
have the additional time we have to
prepare further but it's worth
remembering that so part of the
challenge is the fact that a lot of that
preparation is with third parties it's
with third parties in terms of
businesses or with other member states
and one of the difficulty has been that
Parliament has voted to take no deal off
the table and therefore understandably
businesses then question whether it is
worth preparing me for something if they
think that Parliament has allocated
money the issue is that there is no
guarantee that the eu27 will grant an
extension that is in the UK decision on
the 31st of October so that would be a
matter for the EU so we do need to
prepare for New Deal and ensure that we
use the time we have to mitigate any
disruption as best we can don't ask the
president of the EU Council when that
extension was granted had a message to
within that period the talks have failed
with labour the deal has just been
brought back again with no sign that
it's actually going to get through this
time
and now it looks like the Conservative
Party are about to embark on another
leadership contest is that really using
the time wisely the fact is the
government has reached out here has
recognized we don't have a majority you
say you're so sober there's some my own
colleagues who despite being bricks or
tears have refused to back leaving and
then sure we would have left what we've
we reached out and we've we've sought
discussions I think progress has made me
the prime minister has been clear that
there has been progress in the talks the
fundamental issue for the Labour Party
to decide is is it prepared to do a deal
or is it the case that too many of their
MPs now will refuse any sort of deal
because they want a secular friend is it
time for a new leader for the concept of
politics well the Prime Minister has sat
out the timescale in terms of her own
will and I think what's being clear from
the
the messages i've had from the community
now between speaking to is how much they
appreciate the commitment that Prime
Minister has made to ensuring no hard
border in Northern Ireland - at the UK's
commitments under the Good Friday
Agreement and when I was meeting with
sat there's a real recognition that the
Prime Minister has paid a significant
personal price you've been but she
sacrificed her Premiership in order to
fight for a deal to safeguard the
commitments in terms of the the border
here so Prime Minister sent that out
she's committed to securing a deal she's
then with the 1922 committee as you well
know set out the process there but the
key issue for the prime minister for the
governor as a whole for the community
here for businesses like this is to see
if we can leave with a deal because
that's what they want to see happen it
feels everybody almost on the concept of
benches is about to throw their hat in
the ring so this is your chance are you
going to rule yourself in or out well
the good thing about my job is I have so
much to do I don't need to be posing in
kitchens and doing things what we've got
to focus on what I am doing is focusing
on getting the deal over the line that
is what is our priority that's a
priority for my department is absolutely
core to what we set up to do they can
use in the name Sophie which is exiting
the European Union I campaigned to leave
I support leaving every opportunity I
have voted to leave he's important we
leave for a deal that's a clear message
from communities like this and that is
what I'm doing in those while I'm 100%
focused on anything else is premature I
would say to my colleagues focus on the
day job concentrate on what is before
theirs ensure we deliver on what we
promise to the public ensure that we
leave so you're not ruling us out do you
think first Johnson would be a good
Prime Minister I think all of my
colleagues have talents it will be for
others to weigh up at which of those
takes primacy but I think the key issue
is that we ensure that Jeremy Corbyn is
not Prime Minister because I think if
you look at their plans he's bringing
forward on nationalization if you look
at the plans he has to wreck our economy
he's position in terms of national
security I think here we are a complete
disaster for our countries so any of my
colleagues would be preferable to an
outcome where we were
Oh Jeremy Corbyn government in nearby
Enniskillen it was hard to find a leave
voter I would a robber Ramin because
everyone was dead on forearms of Nations
it doesn't seem to be happening you know
anytime soon well he vaca Thursday where
I'm going that's what you'd like to
happen the council breaks it all
together absolute support who's been
through so much really in the last 30
years that it's just another blow
yeah I think it's gonna happen anyway
and that's gonna be terrible for us here
yeah what do you think the consequences
could be well I don't really know you
know but I know it's not gonna be good
yeah I mean I'm I'll be terrified that
it would cause it would cause violence
you know because when it comes in at
border which there well then obviously
it was one of the massive problems there
is a real fear here that no deal would
lead to the return of a hard border yet
with sluggish progress on any brexit
agreement it is once again rising up the
political agenda